hey guys it's dense the founder of thick
hair and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of HBO's True detective
episodes two and three yeah last one so
you have the same thing seeing things in
the locked room yeah you were gone last
week so we're doing at a two-for-one in
this episode so yeah I'm still really
liking the show I like the pace that
it's going it's it's a slow burn
nobody's picking up y'all ready to pick
up especially with episode 3 bills are
with episode 2 you know I mean one of
the first things I'm sure anyone who
follows me on Twitter saw my tweet about
true detective all I wrote was alexandra
daddario good god like yeah yeah it's
like me yeah yes Woody Harrelson's
character a heart his nails a heart his
mistress that is sleeping with yeah yeah
she's pretty she's a looker yes she's a
looker yeah um but anyways so yeah but
then because of that whole like he his
whole mistress thing he gets in that
fight with with rust yeah in the police
locker rooms the next day cuz Russ can
tell you know Russ is a very sharp guy I
mean it was kind of cuckoo right he's
very observant he can tell that he's
messing around on his wife rustling guy
like rustic is he doesn't the only
hangup he seems to have beside he's a
little crazy and he's got some issues
obviously with his daughter who's dead
and these guys mission some drugs you
know this drug yeah we're drug addiction
illegal in undercover and I think he got
addicted to the drugs that he had to
take right and now he's the episode
routine thinks he sees things right
sometimes he gets hallucination right
which he kind of describes even further
in episode 3 when he's at the bar you
know that the line dancing place and he
can see like he's like I see a color of
yellow and it gives me the sensation so
but as crazy as he is it he doesn't
sleep that much either so he's just up
all night looking at pictures and
studying Case Files like it's funny like
every time woody comes in the more he's
like I'll tire either he's hungover he
didn't sleep and he's like hey I got
some like every
I got some boss I got some you know and
it's really good i love their i love
their relationships it's really good
well yeah it's very tension-filled
because they're very different yes very
different people which will you know you
see more of it in episode 3 but yeah in
episode 2 yeah like even when they're
fighting the in the locker room Russ is
like you know I can break your arms
right now yeah in in in in Woody
Harrelson's character heart he he he
seems to justify all the stuff the bad
stuff that he does he thinks he's a I
know he thinks he's a good guy you know
and I mean in the third episode he does
question you know Matthew McConaughey
says you know do you ever think you're a
bad man you know and I can I says no
it's like of course like we're bad man
we keep the bad men away from the door
or something like that and you know
woody you know if we saw about his
marriage he's always like you know when
you're a family man you have
responsibilities as he's of course you
know going this girl's house you know
and you know pushing her boyfriend you
know on the ground and breaking doors
and just being an idiot everything we
you know what you think a good husband
should be he's not what I preach about
rust at least rust really talks a lot of
like crap and high mumbo jumbo like blah
blah blah existentialism all that
luckily she's honest well he's at least
on is a nihilist and yeah rust is a
nihilist yeah in in the reason why these
analysis because you know we learned
about his yes his kid get it yeah I
guess hit by a car way you know it's a
life is all meaningless and just yeah
because he didn't he finds no meaning in
life anymore because that happened to
him right unjustly he doesn't find like
he doesn't see like well that happened
to me I was living a good life he was
married right wasn't do anything he
wasn't doing anything wrong and this
horrible horrific it's like the worst
thing that can happen to you oh sure
yeah I lose your little daughter yeah
it's awful yeah it's awful so he is you
know out there and then everything you
know and he has that whole conversation
in the beginning of episode three with
heart when they're at the hurt and you
know and it's like well they could you
tell me what the average age of the
aisle with the average IQ is it is true
yeah so busy he's talking down about
these people
in heart is is kinda the normal one in
the sense of he's like no you know why
do you always have to be like that idea
judges people in russ's basically just
being Rost yeah those a great scene of
course you know nice teen uh let's
forget his name was called Nucky's
brother yeah more like a lie from
boardwalk empire's great seen him you
this is this popping up everywhere he's
ever all wolf of Wall Street American
hustle right and now true detective days
again some great roles you know and I
was great seeing him there and we just
great actor and it just is just great
scenes that means sometimes this show so
dark like the comedies you gotta like
it's real subtle it is good comedy but
it's very subtle because it's such
there's no like you know beats well yeah
sometimes it's banter back and forth
between them because the one of the
discussions they had it was it was
tension filled but it was it was a the
whole you know uh rust was giving heart
[ __ ] amount he's like oh I'm glad you
can like let yourself off so easy you
know like he's like because he's treated
heart justifies everything he does I go
along a man's gotta do what a man's got
it right got it you know he's got to
relieve the tension and he's got to do
all this and and he's basically
justifying his drinking he justifies his
extramarital affair and stuff like that
rust is like look man you gotta you know
you can't you can't like use those as
excuses no no I mean rust like i said i
think he is the most honest of the two
at least at this point i want to know
what happened to his kid rust character
to make him I guess go off the deep end
to just this is like he's almost given
up on life like I don't know what his
job is now but I'm assuming he's not
detective anymore it looks like Woody
Harrelson's character wishing to see
probably not married anymore remember
soon though his wife in dec eight years
with his left hand and he says not the
wedding right not anymore but like what
happened to rush so no what happened to
drive him away for maybe he just had
enough I don't know I want to see what
happens we got kicked off I mean yeah
the more likes no one likes him even
though he does good work he doesn't get
along he doesn't follow like the the
policeman's code and
Brotherhood and everything like that so
I could see him easily getting booted
out especially especially if he has a
split which they basically said from
heart you know if rusted hard aren't
friends anymore and heart was kind of
the one keeping him still in it it was
like a Luthor they're together for seven
years so it'll be curious to see how far
they show us into that relationship I
get closer no sir and then eventually
fall I mean yeah another funny scene was
the one where Hart kasbah home and he
sees that rust has been mowing his lawn
right they they just do what you mow my
grass yeah I like my law look what I
want to mow my lawn I liked I love the
conversations between Matthew
McConaughey Michelle Moynihan's
character I really like their their
dialogue it's interesting because
they're both characters were kind of I
guess I gonna call him on the fringes a
little bit because she's not really in
the best relationship right now with her
husband and russ has issues missing his
daughter like he always kind of stares
longingly at you know the two girls you
know he misses his life yeah he misses
like he sees michelle monaghan and yeah
he's like oh you know I he's attracted
her like oh this could be my life she
could be right wide right these could be
my two kids right type of thing and then
in and I think he holds that against
heart because he's not appreciating that
exactly on her and all that stuff actly
not spending time where I am and and
then I think hard smart enough to
realize there is some sort of kind of
chemistry between his wife and Russ he
also knows that was great is you know
kind of a small scene but i love it when
they show a rust dancin with a girl he's
good like the girls have a good time but
Lee can see his eyes he's just not there
he doesn't care he's like he dropped her
off he said goodbye he said he walked
through the door he was respectful and
nice about it but he's just not there in
the moment emotionally it's almost seems
like he has nothing left to give
emotionally and we talked about this in
the first episode this is a like a cop
show it's but you know there's a serial
killer but really it's mainly about
these two characters yeah this is a lot
of just character moments right you know
the plot of the whole case that they're
on develops kind of slowly we have them
going to the
at trailer you know the runaway girls /
prostitutes that where heart kind of
gets uppity in a way again he gets
uppity like all these girls are doing
this it's like come on man it's like
you're basically I mean the girls are
prostitutes sleeping with but still it's
like come on man it's like oh she's
younger yeah and whatnot but you know
he's you know really upset about this
and then you know through their dire
that's where they find that church huh
yeah with the painting on it with the
antlers and they're like okay there's
actually yeah there's something here
someone here that was part of this
church or part of this organization or
attended it is part of this whole
Ritualist at killing and now at the end
of episode three I love how they set it
up because before she the guy with the
gas mask and underwear you know
something like I like that he's talking
about in the interview what here else is
gonna like a gunfight like wait you
haven't up with a gunfight you know and
all this stuff he's like how can it's
like you guys ever been in the gunfire
they get fired your gun to like no it
was like well I'm gonna talk about a
gunfight so we know we're gonna see some
type of shoot out next week we know it's
gonna happen so I'm excited I was a
great way to end the episode just seeing
that crazy living unit with a gas mask
yeah because they were chasing a bunch
of different leads and this is the one
that seems to have panned out this guy
was crazy and I wonder if he is the tall
guy with the scar when we know we don't
know yet am as well we'll find out next
episodes yes so I'm really liking how
this shows going great acting great
directing rewriting yeah it can be slow
but it it's you know I'm fine with it
yeah it's like boardwalk where it's it's
it's going at it space building
everything up right if for those you see
no don't you watch a little bit of a you
know top of the lakes the same way these
like you know call miniseries in a way
because this is gonna be like detectives
gonna be like good it's gonna be in the
miniseries category in the award show
cuz it's gonna like American Horror
Story yes is gonna this story's gonna
end they're gonna change stories change
active range everything's good idea yeah
yeah so I'm really like Anna let let us
know what you thought you can post your
comments below on the website thank hero
calm or on YouTube page think hero pro
make sure you subscribe to that we're
also on Twitter gonna chat with Dennis
myself Michael tell us about true
detective other HBO shows anybody
watching girls out there I like girls
is at think hero i'm at griffin d and we
also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and share our
videos on Twitter Facebook and other
social media